I'm here at Google i/o and I'm pretty  excited about this weird-looking thing  here this is the new jump camera that  Google worked on with GoPro they  essentially stacked 16 GoPro  high-definition cameras on this like  little circular rig here and Google is  gonna be having these at YouTube studios  so that their video creators can come  and take this thing out and shoot and  then you'll be able to watch them on  YouTube starting this summer on your  phone using a device like this one they  announced this thing last year at Google  i/o it's basically a piece of cardboard  this is the newest version of it you'll  be able to stick your phone inside put  it over your face like this and then  watch virtual reality videos like I was  talking about before it's pretty wild  Facebook spend about two billion dollars  to buy oculus you can go online and buy  one of these for about 19 bucks today  can a twenty dollar cardboard thing in a  UFO looking camera compete  we'll find out this summer